economist Joseph Stiglitz on the 2008
economic collapse and its effect on the
global economy on afterwards on c-span
tues book TV Washington journal
continues senator Bernie Sanders is an
independent from Vermont and a member of
the Budget Committee welcome to the
program sir good to be with your own
tell us what about the President's
budget do you like and what do you
dislike I liked the fact that he's in
his budget beginning to address some of
the major crises facing our country
which for many many years were not dealt
with our he is putting a lot of money
into childcare which is absolutely a
terribly necessary he is putting money
into Pell grants so that when kids
graduate college they will not be as
deeply in debt as they are right now
it'll make college more affordable he's
putting money into sustainable energy
and energy efficiency which is also of
enormous consequence because we have to
break our dependence on foreign oil and
I think we create jobs by becoming
energy independent is putting money into
health care I'm especially pleased that
he's understands the importance of
primary health care they need to have
more community health centers around
this country so people can walk in and
get the health care they need when they
need it putting more money into primary
health care doctors because we need that
as well so I think there's a lot to be
said for his much I think it's moving us
in a direction that we should be going
in terms of changing our national
priorities I think he's also right in
terms of saying that we have got to
begin to repeal the tax breaks the
President Bush gave to the wealthiest
people in this country as you may know
we have as a nation the most unequal
distribution of wealth and income where
I disagree with the President as I would
be more aggressive on that when the top
1% earn more income than the bottom
fifty percent top 1% own more wealth in
the bottom ninety percent I would repeal
those tax breaks right now in fact move
toward a more progressive tax system I
think also I disagree with the president
in that when we're looking though in
terms of those agencies where we want to
cut I think at a look at every agency
including the Pentagon in my view there
are a number of weapons systems out
there that many experts
designed to fight the cold war not
international terrorism I think we got
to take a hard look at that bottom line
is this country has enormous problems
our middle class is in very very deep
trouble I think this budget begins to
move us in the right direction are you
concerned about how the president wants
to pay for this budget arm I think his
less so than other aspects of the budget
I think that he is also understanding
that in the midst of this very severe
recession which is leaving seventeen
percent of our people unemployed or
underemployed that one of the things you
have got to do is though everything that
we can to protect the middle class and
to create jobs and that while we are
have got to address obviously the huge
national debt that we have and the fact
that he was given just a terrible
deficit situation from the bush
administration the most important point
that I think we have got to address
right now his jobs and our economy we're
talking about the president's fy2011
budget with senator Bernie Sanders
independent of Vermont and a member of
the Senate Budget Committee if you want
to get involved in our conversation 20
27 37 triple zero one four Republicans
Democrats 20 27 37 triple 0 2 and
independence can call us at 20 to 60 to
80 205 walk us through if you will the
budget process the the budget was
delivered yesterday the Senate Budget
Committee has started to bring folks in
to talk about their various agencies the
house will do the same then what happens
from there ah we will be hearing from
Peter Orszag who's director of OMB I
believe today as a matter of fact and he
will give us an overview of the budget
tell us where the president is coming
from and obviously respond to questions
I think we're going to be hearing from
the secretary of the Treasury this week
as well and then there'll be a lot of
debate and discussion about the budget
what the
Budget Committee does is deal with broad
categories it does not go into the
details of the Defense Department of the
Department of Education but it broadly
suggests as to how much money we should
be spending and in what what categories
and the appropriations committees do the
rest and then the after this goes
through the this whole process the
budgets are crafted by both
appropriations committees then it goes
to the obviously the Senate will vote on
its budget right house will vote on its
budget then you go to conference
committee in your experience what's the
likelihood that the the budget that
comes out of this that comes out of
Congress is going to look anything like
the budget that the president proposed
yesterday based on base lot all history
it probably won't and there will be a
lot of debate I think what we should
understand is that and I say this as an
independent was disagreed with the
President on a number of issues but I
think what we have got to understand is
when President Obama was one in he
inherited the worst set of problems
since the Great Depression of 19 when
Roosevelt came in 32 and it ain't easy
stuff we have a middle class which in
many ways that many ways is really
disintegrating we have a 12 trillion
dollar national debt on the bush the
national debt grew doubled we have two
wars we have a health care system which
in many ways it is really disintegrating
and is not only not providing us the
quality of care what has 46 million
Americans are uninsured I but it is an
economic disaster for this country
because we have ended up spending almost
twice as much as any other country you
got all of these things and we have we
got to deal with these issues and and
and my main criticism of the Bush
administration was not treating the
American people as adults and saying you
know what we got some real real real
serious problems and you just can't push
those problems underneath the rug and I
think the president while I disagree
with them on this on that approach is at
least saying we got to get our act
together you gotta deal with health care
or else you're going to have
unsustainable
uh and deficits in years to come you've
got to deal with global warming well
this planet is going to look at
horrendous situations in terms of
droughts in terms of floods in terms of
mass migrations of people and that we
can move into a new energy system away
from fossil fuels into energy efficiency
and sustainable energy and we can create
millions of jobs as we do that but the
bottom line here as a nation we have got
to understand we can't go back to the
ways that fail we can't push the
terribly serious problems we are facing
underneath the rug we're going to have
to address them and I think if we have
the courage especially to stand up to
the powerful special interests in
Washington who have so much power if we
can do that I am confident that we can
pull this country out of the very
difficult problems that we're currently
facing we want to let our viewers and
listeners know that we will be covering
live on c-span right after this program
today's Finance Committee hearing with
Treasury secretary Geithner coming up to
talk about the 2011 budget and then
later on in the afternoon on the house
side will be at the house budget
committee with Peter Orszag director of
the Office of Management and Budget that
hearing will be taped if you want to see
when it's going to air by all means go
to our website c span org our first
question first caller for senator
Sanders comes from roseburg oregon mike
on our line for democrats go ahead well
good morning gelid and it is an honor
sir to speak with you sir senator bob
well hello young man oh okay i just
wanted to state cert it really I don't
know I I give up I give up I've been a
starch get it I don't know I was one who
believed it basically this is the
country basically is sold out to the
corporate fashion elite ISM that exists
in this country I mean I mean just with
the last that the Supreme Court passing
of this last thing you know corporate
fascism is alive and well kind of Mike
but you know despair is really not an
option if you're saying to me
that our friends on Wall Street whose
greed and recklessness and illegal
behavior plunge this country into the
recession that we're in like right now
and want to go back to the way they used
to be and give themselves huge bonuses
and so forth and so on and if you're
telling me that the heads of the
insurance companies and the drug
companies have enormous power and are
fighting for their own interest in their
own profits at the expense of everybody
else you're absolutely right that is the
reality but despair is not an excuse you
can't say you give up we can't give up
I've got four kids and six grandchildren
beautiful gets all of them I can't give
up you can't give up what we have to do
which is tough stuff is figure out how
did we get to where we are right now was
it a wonderful idea as Alan Greenspan
told us as President Bush told us I know
some Democrats told us that we want to
deregulate everything let Wall Street do
whatever they want uh is that a good
idea is that a great idea that the
Supreme Court recently said corporations
are people and they can contribute as
much money as they want to the political
process not a good idea it's a it's a
horrendous idea the reality is clear we
don't talk about it terribly much in
Congress or on TV a small number of
people who have incredible wealth and
power control a lot of what goes on in
America that's the simple reality now
you can throw your hands up and say it's
too much I can't deal with it or you can
say this is tough stuff this is tough
stuff and how do we once again bring
ordinary people into the political
process how do you create a government
that works for the middle class rather
than the wealthy it ain't easy but
giving up is not an option next up is
Chicago Ralph on our line for
independence go ahead yes thank you
please current we save a trillion
dollars a year by covering alternative
holistic natural therapies and
healthcare considered the cost of
nutrition massage meditation music a
chiropractic natural fatty naturopathy
consider that cost
with surgery radiation chemo there is a
hundred to one saving with alternative
and we could also save and the war on
drugs a trillion dollars well Ralph
interesting question i remember a couple
of years ago in Vermont we had a town
meeting on alternative medicine
competence called complementary medicine
uh and alternative health care and we
had like six hundred people coming out
to Randall off Vermont a small town in
the middle of the state and a cold day
there is a lot of agreement with what
you are saying and I want to tell you
that in the health care bill that is
being debated right now there is a huge
amount of money not going to alternative
health care per se but to disease
prevention dealing with issues like why
are people are becoming obese which
leads to diabetes how can we prevent hot
conditions how can we prevent cancer
rather than just spending a fortune
treating people after they are ill so in
a rational health care system we should
be doing far far better in disease
prevention I happen to agree with you I
think there's a lot to be said for
therapies like acupuncture acupuncture a
massage therapy and and so forth um so I
i agree with you now well that's all I
agree with you and I think it's a good
thing for the American people that we
focus on those issues Lynette has sent
us this message on Twitter she writes Mr
Sanders why is the cap and trade in the
budget when it hasn't been passed yet
well the president the legislation is
not in the budget ideas are in the
budget you know you and that's what a
budget is about but let me say to
Lynette I know people have arguments
about cap and trade people have
arguments as global warming real I
happen to believe global warming is is
very very real but more importantly I
believe that right now we are in the
cusp of an energy revolution and I
applaud the president for putting more
money in the stimulus package into that
revolution of taking us away from
foreign
oil into energy efficiency and
sustainable energy in that one stimulus
package then we have done in the history
of our government and this is what i
believe i believe that if we move
aggressively in terms of energy
efficiency we can cut back substantially
about the amount of energy that we use
right now we are spending and this is
totally off the wall totally insane to
my mind we spend the 350 billion dollars
every single year importing oil from
saudi arabia venezuela and other
countries if you took just a fraction of
that money and you moved it toward
energy efficiency if we had automobiles
that we're getting 50 or 60 miles per
gallon we move to a lecture cause or a
strong presence in terms of hybrid
automobiles if we knew move to mass
transportation in my state of Vermont we
have been very strong in energy
efficiency we're now beginning to move
to such sustainable energies as wind
solar biomass we can create over a
period of time millions and millions of
jobs and break our dependency on foreign
oil that is exactly what we have to go
in that area I think the president has
been strong and we have to be continued
a continue to be aggressive in that next
up is hurricane West Virginia Ruth on
our line from Republicans yeah I would
like to know what you mean by progresses
okay thank you with uh this is what I
mean by being a progressive the vast
majority of the people in our country
are either in the working class or they
are in the middle class or their lower
income we have as I mentioned before a
situation where the top 1% earn more
income than the bottom fifty percent in
that gap between the people on top and
everybody else has grown much wider and
Ruth what I mean by being a progressive
is that I happen to believe that health
care is a right of all people and I
think it's an international disgrace
that the United States is the only
country in the industrialized world and
not a lot of people know that Rob we are
the only country in the industrialized
world that does not guarantee health
care to all of our people as a right of
citizenship and yet we end up spending
almost
twice as much per person on health care
as any other nation and our outcomes are
not particularly good so Ruth when you
asked me what does it mean to be a
progressive it means every person in
this country is entitled to health care
I would also tell your roof that it is
very hard for people to make it into the
middle class or for our country to be
competitive internationally if we don't
have a very strong educational system if
all of our people regardless of income
don't have the capability of going to
college the idea that kids are
graduating college twenty five fifty
thousand dollars in debt then are forced
to get into jobs you know make it a
whole lot of money rather than doing
things that I really like to do I think
is is unfortunate we have the highest
rate of childhood poverty of any major
country on Earth and the corollary of
that is we have more people in jail than
any other country on Earth including
China so Ruth what being a progressive
is about is saying that we should have a
government that begins to address the
real issues facing working people and
the middle class health care for all
making sure that we have a strong social
security and retirement system making
sure that every kid in this country gets
a quality education and it's not just
the Welcome best colleges that's what
being a progressive is about in the
Washington Post this morning there's an
article or actually a graph that shows
winners and losers as they they put it
on from the office of management budget
management and budget of spending by
departments from Veterans affair which
has an increase of 7.3 percent in their
budget from last year down to commerce
which has a reduction of almost
thirty-six percent in their budget from
last year of these changes which one
concerns you the most I'm a member of
the Veterans Committee and I'm very
active on Veterans issues and per month
and around the country and I think for a
number of years we have to be honest
about this the federal government
shortchanged our veterans now you can
agree or disagree Ottawa I was strongly
opposed to the war in Iraq but you can't
be opposed to the men and women who put
their lives on on the line I in that war
came back wounded I sometimes physically
some
x emotionally very high rates of PTSD
very high rates of traumatic brain
injury and in vermont we have worked
very hard with the veterans and we've
got to do this all over the country when
people come back from that war we have
got to protect them and their families
and i think what the president is also
doing for many many years what happened
is we said to veterans that if you're
above a certain income level not very
high by the way your so-called priority
eight and you can't access the VA system
and what President Obama is saying is
that's wrong we're going to bring more
and more of those people back into the
system and I know general Shinseki who
is Secretary of the VA believes in that
I believe in that the committee believes
in that and what we're saying to people
who have put their lives on the line to
defend this country we're not going to
forget about you we did that in the past
when I can do that and not only that if
you're over in Afghanistan right now if
you're over in Iraq we're going to do
everything we can to protect your family
no matter what our views are on the
world I have serious misgivings about
the war in Afghanistan you cannot forget
about the people who put their lives on
line or their families back home and I
think that is one of the reasons why the
veterans budget has increased and I
think the president is right to do that
senator Bernie Sanders independent of
Vermont came to the house of
representatives in 1991 and served there
until two thousand seven he succeeded
jim jeffords and is in the middle of his
first term as a BA from the University
of Chicago back to the phones Riverside
California on our line for Democrats
Rudy go ahead all right I mean Bernie
Sanders is the real deal and my point
being Bruce gagnant he has a great
website on the economy and military and
this new push for a smaller government
is just a ruse to get them away from
social security and some of our
entitlements and now I see that it's
becoming a real threat how can they take
away our social security
and that we that people have paid in to
deny a SAT after denying us healthcare
and what's going to be next everybody
should see Bruce gagging and website
because he's up on his stuff and God
bless you bring thanks Ruby Thank You
Ruby look um here's what the debate is
about we got into this horrendous
deficit situation in national debt
situation how did that happen well let's
talk about it for a second a president
bush thought it was very important to
give huge tax breaks to the wealthiest
people in this country who had already
become much wealthier he forgot to pay
for them but let's going to question a
lot of money President Bush decided that
we wanted to invade Iraq and go into a
wall which over a period of years will
cost trillions of dollars that he
decided we did not have to pay for that
because of the deregulation of the
banking industry which is supported by
both Republicans and some Democrats a
Clinton was there as well the system
virtually collapsed and against my vote
Congress provided seven hundred billion
dollars to bail out Wall Street uh that
wasn't paid for President Bush decided
political reasons I think to provide a
prescription drug program to seniors
which is desperately needed but this
particular one was written by the
insurance companies and the drug
companies are did not ask the government
to negotiate drug prices with the
pharmaceutical industry became an
expensive program unpaid for you had all
of those things together you're looking
to trillions of dollars in debt and now
what some of our Republicans say is
friends who voted for all of these
things by the way they say my goodness
they have suddenly woken up to the fact
that we have a very large national debt
and as Ruby says well one of the ways
that we can deal with the debt is not to
ask the wealthy to pay more in taxes not
to cut back on military spending not to
negotiate drug prices with the
pharmaceutical industry because that
kind of steps on the toes of powerful
special interests but I tell you what we
could do we could slash Medicare for the
people of this country we could move
toward the privatization
of Social Security and cut back on
benefits there those are ways that in
fact you can cut back on the deficit and
and future national debts well I think
that that would be grossly unfair right
now our health care system is in crisis
we have to strengthen Medicare not cut
it back so the one of the debates will
be that is certainly going to be front
and center is how do you deal with a 12
trillion dollar national debt that is
growing do you take it out of the hides
of working people and elderly and
children or do you begin to ask the
wealthiest people to start paying their
fair share of taxes do you start
rethinking our foreign policy and maybe
start ending some wars that we should
not have gotten into in the first place
do you do way with corporate welfare do
you say to the financial institutions in
this country whose greed and
recklessness cause this great recession
they ain't going to go back to where you
were before and in fact we're going to
start taxing you we're going to break up
large financial institutions so we never
have to bail you out again we're going
to put a cap on interest rates so you're
not charging people twenty-five or
thirty percent on their credit cards etc
so basically the future debate over the
debt and deficits has to deal with
woodside all you want next up is Rick on
our line for independence from Cedar
Hill Maryland go ahead hi I was just
calling it it seems like that we've
become a charge card society we're going
to we when we run into a problem we
borrow the money we just constantly
borrow money to fix problems and just
like with the civilian cord things like
that when we brought a lot of people and
it didn't have jobs we turn to our
resources our natural resources and use
those and is there any way we could use
those on basis to actually pay for some
of the green products or you know the
projects along the way for that you know
when you when you're actually mining
something or or or say you're taking the
forests or whatever and you produce and
resources that's that's not something
that that you borrowing it something
you know it's it's it's new it can't be
outsourced right now that's exactly
right Rick and let me give you just a
few examples and I am as the chairman of
the green jobs Committee of the
Environment Committee very excited about
this I think there is unlimited
potential economic potential and job
creation in moving to a new energy
system let me just give you a few just a
few examples you talked about resources
in the northern part of the state of
Vermont there is a small electric co-op
actually it's in Central Vermont which
is providing most of its electricity
pretty cheap electricity you know with
that electricity is coming from from
methane gas that comes from a landfill
got that landfill methane gas providing
electricity in the state of Vermont we
are having now I think close to 40
schools and one hospital that are
providing heat in Vermont's cold winters
with woodchips they come from the local
forests sustainably harvested so you
have in terms of solo there are our
estimates out there that if we tap the
solar energy that comes into the
southwestern part of this country which
is just a wonderful location for solar
energy we can provide close to thirty
percent of the electricity that homes
utilize in this country if we have and
I'm introducing legislation soon for ten
million solar rooftops all over this
country even in the Northeast where
people think you can't utilize solar you
can win we have extraordinary potential
to move away from foreign oil so we
don't spend 350 billion dollars a year
in putting that stuff from Saudi Arabia
develop our own energy and create jobs
doing that I see that is not only
important for energy independence it's
important to deal with greenhouse gas
emissions and global warming and it is
very important for our economy regarding
the process I want to get your reaction
to a statement made by representative
Weiner of New York last week saying that
Republicans are the opposition regarding
the budget but the Senate is the enemy
talk to me about the tension
between the two chambers and area there
is tension and and what congressman
weiner says I can understand that I
spent 16 years in the house the
Republicans have been very clear and
their view has been that if it is good
for Obama it is bad for the Republicans
and the end result has been more
filibusters and delaying tactics on the
7th floor in the last year I believe
that any time and I think at least
certainly in modern history if not the
history of the country they're just
saying no no no what congressman Weiner
is also saying is that because time
after time if they're not a lot of
Americans don't know this they say oh
there are a hundred members of the
Senate I guess 51 carries 51 doesn't
carry the Republicans have threatened to
filibuster and you need 60 votes and you
know what on many issues it is very hard
for us to get 60 votes because you have
some pretty conservative Democrats who
are not you know sympathetic to what's
on the floor and it has slowed up the
process of the house does something and
then there is a real bottleneck in the
Senate and I talked to members of the
House say we keep passing good stuff and
nothing keeps happening as you guys
aren't moving I understand where they're
coming at my own view is that what we
have got to understand is that we don't
have and we certainly don't will not
have 60 votes in a few days but even
when we had 60 votes you don't really
have 60 votes and we have got to develop
a strategy that works with 51 votes and
figure out how with 51 votes we can pass
legislation which may not be as broad
and comprehensive as you could if you
had 60 but that's the way life is our
last call for senator Sanders comes from
Michael on our line for Republicans in
Greenbelt Maryland hi Mr Sanders I just
wanted to say that I appreciate that
you're a real Patriot and they're really
working for the American people and one
of the few people in Congress that I
feel strongly in that way and I just
want you to keep up the good work and
one thing I wanted to bring up is I knew
I remember you being on the floor last
year voting against the tarp bailout of
the big banks and I appreciate that I
just wonder what is your feeling do you
feel the
while some people say that well if we
hadn't done this big bailout that would
be in a worse condition than we are now
I don't know that I truly believe that I
just believe that now government is
going into this thing where we feel that
we can bail everything out and try to
and that says helping people and me is a
small businessman don't feel that we're
getting any relief I'm just trying to
put two kids through college right sorry
to cut you off Michael with well I think
Michael raises a whole lot of good
points what I said is and I remember the
saying mr. Bernanke antha Polson who in
my view were there representing Wall
Street and I said you know you guys and
your friends on Wall Street caused this
problem if you really really think this
bailout is absolutely necessary to tell
you what you do you go back to the
richest people this country the folks on
Wall Street and say we're putting a
surtax on millionaires and billionaires
to pay for the bailout ah that was that
was my view and I think what Michael is
talking about there is a huge
frustration and anger in this country
the government has worked to protect the
interest of Wall Street while ignoring
Michael talks about the fact that he's a
father trying to send kids through
college true in Vermont all over this
country we're putting more money into
Pell grants but we have a lot more to do
and I think what people are saying are
crying out for is hey what about us and
we're working 50 or 60 hours a week it's
not worrying about us and not just the
big money in trust they'll be you know
and I think that's a legitimate concern
senator bernie sanders thanks for coming
on the washington journal this morning
good to be with you roll we're going to
take a short break and when we come back
a discussion regarding the economy and
the Latino community with the president
of La Raza but first this news update
from c-span radio it's nine-thirty 2
a.m. eastern time President Obama and
Russian President Dmitry Medvedev are
offering support for global zero an
international group trying to rid the
world of nuclear weapons President Obama
in a written message to the group says
disarmament is one of his highest
priorities the Russian president calling
it a priority the global zero conference
opened today amid concerns about Iran's
nuclear program and the START treaty an
arms control treaty agree agreement
between the US and Russia that treaty
expired in december of last year and
reports say that talks to renew the
treaty have stalled five american torres
terrorism suspects being held in
pakistan say that they were tortured by
the FBI and pakistani police trying to
frame them the message written on tissue
paper was tossed out to reporters as
they were entering their latest hearing
in court the u.s. embassy spokesman
denies the torture allegations those
five men all young Muslims from the
Washington DC area were detained in
December south of Islamabad not long
after they arrived in Pakistan and it
was nearly one year ago today that a
regional airliner crashed near Buffalo
New York killing 50 people today the
National Transportation Safety Board is
expected to give the cause of the crash
and also make some safety
recommendations the crash revealed